tip number one cut those cards guys real
talk time if a diet tells you to cut it
three major food group dairy grains and
fruits and vegetables it's probably
valued there by cutting out all these
essential foods you're probably going to
be missing out on essential nutrients
vitamins and fiber and leave you
susceptible to overdoing it on fat fiber
is super important for helping you feel
fuller longer and carved help peel your
workouts so that you can actually burn
calories and build muscle rather than
swearing off all carbs just try to focus
on those slow burning ones so swap your
refined grains for some whole grains
your fruit juice for some nice and fresh
or frozen fruit and your cream in your
coffee for some low-fat milk okay so I
won't mess with your coffee but you get
the idea
tip number two do worn or cardio either
done ten thousand million steps today
we've all heard that you need to burn
more calories than you take it in order
to lose weight so slaving away at the
treadmill seems like a good idea right
well maybe not so much research actually
shows that a lot of slow steady state
long cardio sessions can actually start
to burn through your muscle and
therefore decrease your metabolism and a
fast metabolism is really key to burning
those calories even when you're not
exercising and therefore can help you
lose weight
now I'm not discouraging cardiovascular
exercise there are so many important
benefits like helping to reduce blood
pressure blood sugar cholesterol and it
can help you manage your weight when
done correctly I'm just saying to mix in
some strength training exercises with
your cardio and maybe to increase the
intensity and decrease the duration of
those cardio sessions because that may
help you to rev up that metabolism and
burn more fat tip number 3 to reduce
those meals and count those calories the
freer the meals the better I've read
some diets out there that prescribe less
than a thousand calories as a quick
weight loss solution but under eating
almost always that fires with so little
food it's almost impossible to get the
necessary nutrients minerals fiber and
protein to keep you feeling full plus it
can actually prevent muscle gains which
again slows down our metabolism a better
idea would be to focus on portion
control and balance try filling half
your plate with colorful veggies a
quarter err plate with some lean protein
the other quarter whisk until grains in
Adamson's food and some low-fat dairy
throughout the day of snacks trust me
making veggies the star of your plate
will help you to fill up without filling
out
get rid of any of those sweets and
desserts whole lot of us probably
overdid it on the pie and the chocolate
this holiday but completely denying
yourself your favorite food almost
always results in big [ __ ] when we
finally come in contact with it again
enjoying a small mindful treat will help
keep those cravings at bay without
derail in your diet trial square of dark
chocolate and nuts
biscotti or you could blend a frozen
banana with a touch of cocoa powder to
make a great substitute for ice cream
whatever you choose remember that even
when you do indulge one bad food is not
gonna make you gain weight and when good
food is not gonna make you lose weight
it's all about balance and moderation
tip 5 don't have to be
we can thank over for this money but
guys just remember your body doesn't
know what time it is the same dinner at
6:00 p.m. or 9 p.m. is gonna deliver the
same amount of energy where people start
to get into trouble is when they starve
themselves all day slowing their
metabolism down and then binge in front
of the TV on junk food rather than
worrying how late it is twice reading
your calorie counter of the day to help
avoid a ghost angry snack attack and
when you do have a snack before bed go
too slowly with some protein and fiber
to help keep you feeling full until
morning
something like full grain cows needs a
little bit of almond butter whether your
plan is to cut all the carbs run on the
treadmill all day or eat as little as
you possibly can just remember that
those extreme eating plans usually do
more harm than good still thinking of
hopping on that crazy new year's diet I
didn't think so thanks so much for
watching guys more great nutrition tips
and tricks be sure to subscribe to my
channel and I'll see you next time
abby's kitchen